so today so if you want to no no no no  they hate Annie Hathaways business would  you know they never be who's that dog  Sandra Bullock sandra bullocksies is my  girl right here straight up there send a  bullet she's your girl right yes right  now do you know who said do a movie  together  who is that bullocksies half away some  but no i'm talking about some  bullocksies and some hathaways let me  just explain what I'm talking about down  i'm talking about some hathaways and  some bullocksies not you right  oh good yeah I'm good I thought  something was going me two seconds ago  we would transform in some way shape or  form okay  [Music]  [Applause]  you